let's meet the creators and cast of the
Maze Runner right now starting with that
director I was just talking about mr.
West bell ball I'm sorry the author of
the book The Maze Runner
mr. James Dashner he plays Gally in the
film mr. will Poulter Teresa is played
by Kaya Scodelario then lastly as Thomas
mr. Dylan O'Brien west ball by the way
yes Wes ball my bad it's okay that's
embarrassing
Dylan let me ask you as Thomas the
character you play yeah an actor tends
to want to use his environment his
memories the memories he creates for a
character you have none of those
advantages in this character how do you
how did you approach it um
I mean just by doing it I guess but yeah
you're right there's not much to go off
of but that's almost cool it's almost
easy it's very natural for what the
characters going through you know taking
it in just one step at a time having no
recollection of anything any previous
life yeah I don't know it's it's easy in
a way it's it's sort of you know it's
sort of a theme throughout the movie the
mystery and so playing that I guess is
important and and easier when you have
nothing to go off of you know and Wes we
did mention you're a short form ruin
which is terrific it heezy it on youtube
can you go on youtube and see yes sure
yeah you should check it out it's really
pretty it's pretty amazing
um that led to you getting this job and
there's a little bit of a leap from
doing a short film to a film of this
magnitude in this scale what was the
process like that got you this
particular project yeah I mean basically
I got a little bit of a
tension off of that little short I think
probably because of the overgrown
concrete aspect of it all so while I was
at the studio talking about that project
they gave me this book to read and asked
me what I would do with it so I went
home and read it and I immediately kind
of fell in love with well I fell in love
with the core concept and the characters
themselves and I just the idea of a
group of boys trapped in this world for
what we'll find out is a period of years
having to create their own little world
you know and and come up with their own
little society in this place without any
kind of outside any outside intervention
it was a really cool idea for that kind
of survival istic aspect of like Lord of
the Flies and those kinds of things I
love that kind of stuff and then on top
of that just the kind of menacing aspect
of the maze outside that surrounding
this place it lent itself to some really
fun situations lots of tension lots of
suspense it was just a chance to kind of
do something really cool and big on
adventure and try to do something a
little differently than what most things
have done coming before us where we do
something that has a little bit more
balls to it you know so it was it was a
lot of fun and I guess this to you liked
what I had to say and and and here we
are now you guys had a screening of the
film last night is that right yeah it's
right yeah and apparently the reaction
was some phenomenal some of these did
you see it
so have you folks see this screening
last night yeah James what's it like as
an author to see these characters these
situations this story that sprung from
your mind up on the screen like it's
indescribable man I get I get really
emotional when I saw the the final
version of the film recently I mean I
was shaking I was bawling I was it was
just something I could probably never
experience again but they really
captured my vision and Wes and this
amazing beautiful cast especially will
Poulter look how beautiful Oh Dylan you
know he's fine anyway they created this
they took the vision of my book and
turned it in this magnificent film I
seriously just I can't wait for you guys
to see it
well let's take a look at some more of
the
and the actors I think we've got this is
the first look for the trailer right
yeah this is our second trailer
basically the new trailer new trailer
first time anyone is seeing it you guys
here in Hall H we're going to show you
the brand new trailer for the Maze
Runner I'd like to start off by asking
will gali in the film he has sort of
cross-purposes with with Thomas's Dylan
character in terms of how they approach
their situation and their destiny
he talked a little bit about your
character Sherman I'm still freaking out
a little bit after that was really
awesome we haven't seen like properly
does that was cool for us yeah so so
Gally was a really interesting challenge
to me and like to again Basel my thanks
to Wes who trusted me with the role it
was a lot of fun I mean I guess he's the
closest thing to the villain in the
story but really what I think we tried
to do collaboratively it is create a
character who was more conflicted than
just kind of one way inclined and
villainous I think a lot of what was in
James's book and a lot of what ended up
being on the page was kind of rational
and and empathetic from from Gally I
think you could see his side of the
story even if he didn't necessarily
agree with it you kind of saw where he
was coming from which was important for
me you know and I I actually respected
the kid I kind of I could appreciate his
point of view but I suppose the main
thing about galley which we kind of drew
out is that he's a bit of a cowards and
he is totally willing to be confined to
the glade which is that kind of
manufactured environment that you see
encased in the four walls he's made that
his home and he's fearful of what is
kind of on the outside world and there's
allusions to maybe you know the fact
that he has some memory of what might be
out there
whereas Dylan has this I think well
sorry I should say Thomas has this we
love each other in real life can I just
say we're like full-on you know it's
fully romantic but Thomas kind of seems
to have this guttural sort of
instinctive
to escape and so we're at polar
opposites of the spectrum and you know
that's why I'm a couple occasions of
almost comes to blows between the two of
us where we would kind of hate each
other in the film which I guess you'll
see
okay let's talk a little bit about being
the only female amongst not only in the
role of Teresa amongst all these guys at
the glade but also as yourself as an
actress as well what was your experience
like and it was wonderful I mean I've
grown up around a lot of guys and loads
of my friends are boys and I really like
the fun you can have around boys because
they kind of talk crap a lot and it's
fun we had a wonderful time you're kind
of bonded straight away and and it's
it's I feel so comfortable with them
it's very kind of Brotherly because they
look after me but they also bully me and
it's nice as I feel like I'm on the same
level as them and it just helped me
understand her so much more and and her
need to be as strong as possible and
just survive straight away so to be able
to prove herself which I think she does
right and I think that's basic is like
in this story there really isn't much of
a love story between the two it's it's
more of a mysterious connection that
plays itself out over the narrative and
and something hopeful will be able to
explore further but it helped that you
basically kiyah became kind of one of
the boys with the throw down with the
best of them so let's go out to the
audience for a couple questions hi there
what's your question I'm Kayla
I was just wondering like in particular
if you had any scene that you found like
the most fun to shoot or anything like
that
let's ask all the actors that what was
the was the most fun and the most
grueling experiences for you making the
film um every scene was most grueling
hmm yeah old movies most trailer yeah I
sacrifice limbs on this movie the most
fun was uh
I don't know I really really liked our
restaurant scene no bump that was just
one that was awesome that we rehearsed
from you know a week before we started
production and we didn't shoot it till
about three weeks in and it's just such
a scene that kind of reminds me of you
know movies that I loved as a kid
growing up and it's you know I love to
that it's sort of for Thomas the first
kind of glimpse you get into see and how
strong is you know you know he takes on
Gally in the ring and it's really cool
it's really fun it's a great scene yeah
I would echo dill said and say that that
was kind of one of my favorite scenes as
well and then and then also like weirdly
the scenes where you know we really get
into it as characters and we're like
facing off for each other and this isn't
something you'd maybe expect on a
platform as big as you know a fox film
like this and in a film that you know
was based on such a popular novel but
you know we also got a lot of
opportunity to to really act in this
movie you know we were allowed to
improvise
we were really allowed to bring our own
thoughts and and and ideas to the table
you know and sorry Kayla this is real
question should be there since to you
and you know Wes is all about
collaboration I should also say we
weren't laughing at you by the way there
was someone being an idiot behind you so
that's wait that's why we were laughing
it wasn't it wasn't you and I think I
just got flicked off thank you sir
that's awesome well wrestle yeah okay
what about you for me what I enjoyed the
most me and Dylan spent a day on top of
a tree together and it was just so
random and it kind of is the beauty of
this job it's this gorgeous treehouse
thing that was built specifically for
the film and was really big and was a
real tree and swung in the wind and and
it was the first day where we we'd
become friends but I think it's where we
kind of really spent time together as
actors and and kind of juggled with each
other and for me it was just a beautiful
day of work because I got to just be
one-on-one with him and see the magic
that he makes
and and it was really pretty out there
as well my favorite scene was the one
scene that I was in there is a candy you
guys got to look for me in the movie all
right all right we will hi there what's
your question
hi um I actually have a question for
kaya um I'm a big fan of fear from
seeing skins yeah not the American one
right the English one um so I was
wondering how your character developed
it was different when filming this than
from playing Effie I had a I had a lot
of time with Effie I was 14 when I
started playing her so I kind of I lived
out my teenage issues through her and I
was going through all those things at
the same time and she was a very deep
carrot such as a very important
character to me but with this it was fun
because I could just be completely angry
and you know hungry
and I loved that about this character
she arrives and she's not trying to make
friends with anyone you know she's not
kind of paying mediator between people
she just wants to survive and she wants
to know who she is and where she is and
there's something I really admire about
her that I kind of I haven't really had
before with the character she kind of
you know she she made me feel a bit
braver and that you know the whole thing
I think as a young woman sometimes you
feel like you have to fit a certain box
and you have to be a certain person and
both Effie and Theresa will always their
own people and I really respect that and
I kind of wish I could be a little bit
more like that sometimes but they both
really inspire me I'm glad I got to play
both of them great thanks
hi there what's your question hi I'm
Angelica um my question was was there
anything in the book that didn't quite
make it to the movie that you wish would
have well that's why migration
it's what these two like have a full on
fire gonna wrestle no there's the
obvious challenge as a turning a book
into a movie but um I think I think
basically we all but although Elvis is
the favorite scenes of the fans half of
the book will be in the movie you know
we definitely changed stuff that I
thought like wouldn't be
visual or things that just that wouldn't
play cinematic like they do and a novel
but it was all about sort of you know
condensing down the story and and making
sure that the escalation of tension and
sort of suspense and all that great
stuff and momentum was the important
thing of the movie so anything that kind
of fell away was usually in that sense
but I'm not gonna give away the spoilers
of what they are sorry
you know if anybody would be the
harshest critic you'd think it would be
me because I wrote the book and I can
just I can honestly tell you that every
change that had to be made made perfect
sense and helped the spirit of the book
translate even better than the literal
translation would have to the big screen
you guys you're gonna love it that is
not a worry hi there what's your
question I with all of the why a
dystopian movies and books out there
Maze Runner is one of one of the few
that actually has a male character
that's really strong and really
developed how do you think Thomas will
hold up in more of a general crowd at
the movies because they see people like
Tris prior caps Everdeen or you know
which one won't win the fight whichever
you want to answer yeah I mean I don't I
don't know if if Thomas would you know
beat Katniss in a fight or anything I
think she'd take him out with an arrow
before he could even get to her he'd run
and run away he could dodge yeah I don't
know it's it's funny hearing that you
know I I forget that yeah a lot of these
why a movies that are out remember
strong female roles I think that's great
I think usually what I'm used to has
seen a lot of strong male roles it's
great that I get to play one I'm really
in love with this character I love kind
of how he you know he gets a fresh start
and a new chance at discovering things
inside him that he never knew you had on
his life before and I think in this
specific age the case it's courage and
strength and a sense of leadership you
know and and it's great to kind of
was journey you know starting as the
greening the Nubian kind of following
his just sort of utter defiance
throughout the film and and not willing
to just go along with everything and not
willing to just let his fear you know
kind of hold him hold him back
he sort of genuinely rather die than
spend the rest of his life in that Glade
so yeah I don't know it's it's it's a
blessing to play you know it's really
cool and I'm sort of a really big fan of
like you know that kind of ordinary kids
and extraordinary circumstances you know
that's so those are sort of my favorite
movies growing up so it's great to get
to play you know and portray yeah
besides the maze which is the most
obvious hurdle in front of these
characters what they're dealing with the
the thing that terrifies me are the
grievers can we talk about those just a
little bit Wes how did you bring those
to the screen in order to convey the
terror that they certainly do in James
book yeah the grievers are obviously you
know very key parts of the book these
kind of guard dogs that are out in the
maze and sort of terrorize these kids as
they try to just escape this place
they are basically their greatest fear
they're they're very cool they're there
for me I was I was looking at things
like Jurassic Park an alien and those
kinds of movies and the opportunities
that I had to kind of play up the kind
of monster movie aspects of this thing
and so designing it was was actually a
lot of fun it was me and another
designer named Ken Barthelme we
communicated basically to over email and
and design this thing together and I
hand it off to Method and they kind of
brought it to life but it was really
just taking sort of the basic ideas that
James put in the book and that the
general idea of being sort of a
Frankenstein a sort of biomechanical
creation is what was an intriguing idea
and I think you'll notice that and I'm
trying very hard to and in the in the
marketing not give away these things too
much because I believe in the idea of
surprise in the theater so you'll
probably the the massive mass audience
out there probably won't ever get our
truly good look at these things but
I guess we are here with just a bunch of
friends so so what we've done for you
guys if you can not spoil too much to
everyone outside of here is we've cut
together one particular scene where
Thomas kind of has a little encounter
one of these guys and you'll get a
little taste of what the rest of the
movie hasn't stored I am
I was just wondering in the book you see
that the characters got their names from
significant people in history and you
mentioned that mean Howe was a name that
you kind of created but I was wondering
about frypan because who would really
that is a very specific question very
good you know in the very first draft of
the Maze Runner we find that we found
out that frypan's real name was siggy
which is probably why he goes by frypan
so you can do a little brainstorming and
research and see who he might have been
named after with the name siggy saying
I'll leave it at that
oh good sure Chris Sigmund yes I win I
think it's time for one more question
I am Nika and our questions for Dylan we
just wanted to say though we loved you
and our question is what was the most
difficult scene you filled um thank you
guys first of all so sweet I love the
door
Chuck's death spoiler OH
sorry man I lit her a lot of pressure at
the end we're gonna forget he said that
she didn't hear that someone's death in
the film okay that we know that there is
more to the story that doesn't all wrap
up nice and neat in the first book
there's two more books that tell the
story across the yeah what's very cool
about us-- abandoning this this seems so
weird we show them the griever we can't
talk about something that's in the book
that's the true it is in the book it is
in the book but don't tell everyone else
who don't know that right most of you
already forgotten what he said anyway
yeah if you hadn't read the book have
you guys read the book most people who
read it we forgive you Dylan it's
alright maybe seen the agreement there's
a lot of people that die yeah Darth
Vader's at Lucy I was their father
you guys are mean what I didn't know
that you could it mean good sorry this
is going horribly other plans for
filming the next two books as well yeah
so yeah scorch trials is due what's very
interesting about this book has got a
pretty damn Falls the ending that you
know we are we see this as you know
potentially being a really cool saga to
tell and multiple movies of course I
mean it is it does fit into that zone
but we think that we could do something
really really special with the next one
based on the characters and sort of the
the the family that you kind of learned
to love in this in this this first movie
and we are really excited about possibly
being able to you know of course it all
depends if you guys all go out and see
the movie being able to possibly you
know make this thing into a real true
saga where we can really open up the
story and have a lot more you know a lot
more suspense and scares and and a lot
more kind of drama and really good you
know character story stuff and what's
really great about the sequel that James
wrote is that it's in a completely
different environment than our first
maze now I guess we probably should show
something we we might be kind of gearing
up possibly to shoot it may be and you
know fall or this this winter basically
again if assuming everything goes well
but it is it is it could be something
really truly spectacular and you know I
think maybe do we have something maybe
anything up there to show nothing I want
to show something that you was that
being else this is look this is
basically the world that we're going to
wind up in and it's very cool and and
you really have to just watch the movie
and we don't answer every single
question there's some things that we
leave open and we get to hopefully
explore them in the next one where we
get to go into this really cool world
and do some more really fun stuff so
please oh hopefully you guys liked
everything you saw here and you can tell
all your friends to go see this movie so
we can make a sequel
that's great I'm guessing Chuck won't
show up in scorch trials that's my guess
he does actually little do you know
Dylan just you guys could be the
greatest cocoa mokona have bug yeah
great I'm throwing a curve oh yeah yeah
well thanks guys for showing up if
you're talking about the film is showing
us that great footage please help me
thank thanks guys
our French director Wes ball James
Dashner will culture pious total Aereo
and Dylan O'Brien
[Applause]
you